you take it we got to get that wig off
of him before dude you're like well i
hold you down
you look like sharon taint
back off my broccolini
halloween so what's your costume huh
where's your costume
no you're the manager of the island boys
that just looked like a regular tuesday
for theo though
yeah yeah it's just normal yeah do you
know about it water dick look at you
yeah
that's that detroit water so yeah we got
this thing buzzed man that's from flint
we flew that one from flint man we
bougie around here
is this mine
periodically got the periodic table in
it huh
hey i guess christian's a ghost
christian put that back
i guess that's a ghost yeah we'll go
with that i don't know if that's the
best choice
oh i like it yeah yeah
i'm surprised income is that stevie look
cool bub thanks man i put an effort cb
went indian please huh construction code
are you really off of singing more space
i was thinking more sex trafficking i
thought it was a butt plug you know what
i mean no it's a cone
oh yeah yeah
seen you before yeah like a cone like a
jewish person no like a construction
cone like a car oh like a street cone a
car i thought you were like a cohen oh i
thought you're like i thought you're
like a surprise character from squid
games
unexplained
i knew you guys would do this too i'm
ready
keep it coming i knew you guys were
gonna do this silence peasant
i like theo sex trafficking if you
pulled it pulled it out through the
front that's sex trafficking yeah i like
that and if sex trafficking gets real
busy they need cones you think so
and sometimes thailand
bumper to bumper can't believe you said
butt plug whoever said that yeah what
you knew that was coming come on
by the way i just want to say about this
costume this is not my fault you look
great for all the hate that's going to
come my way because you're the official
racial profiling yeah
no my my uh so i was in washington and i
called my girl and i said i need a
costume for tuesday
she goes she goes okay i'll get you a
costume and this was the only one that
was double xl
i wanted something else i wanted it was
something like this me too it was like a
dinosaur or something but she got this
instead because she got the matching
outfit so she has a the outfit but then
i said you don't understand what's going
to happen i'm going to go on this
podcast where i get all this hate on the
internet why would they hate that you
look great
now i'm official it's like i've
officially taken over or something
this is the hate that's going to come
can i just say this too
guys this podcast isn't government-run
okay i didn't get a letter from the
government that said i am now assigned
to king of the sting these two
[ __ ] ask me to come on the
podcast no we love it okay so all you
haters out there the f there's only five
of them
on instagram
they hit me up too yeah there's five on
instagram that these loser trolls that
have to say something about me every
single week like i want to thank all the
like theo was right he told me said
you're gonna get some love at the shows
and by the way a lot of king and sting
fans came out in arlington at the draft
house and then they come up to me in the
picture line they're like yo bro king of
the sting love you one so i know that
the real fans that come out and actually
spend money
i appreciate you you guys you just
aren't loud on the internet like these
people because they have lives dumbass
troll [ __ ]
and you know who i'm talking about
you just you just put a you just put a
post up right now oh they hit me up too
dude they get real personal with you
yeah they took a break from protesting
chappelle and hit you guys up dude did
you see chappelle's video yeah you can't
hate on that guy's the best he went on
he went in he went in yeah he was
doubling down wait hold on that's my
costume i'm a netflix uh employee
who are you gonna call are you okay
okay it's special i get it no i'm
kristen wiig from ghostbusters
um i think you're more i think because
i'm also a netflix pro no no i think
because of your size
about you like this baby
you like that thick rat on his shoulder
yeah i know you see that thick rat
see these makeups uh
i'm here i'm here i'm here up here
manager for the island
they're making new ghostbusters yeah did
you see the trailer yeah the kids go
yeah it looks good
by the way was dude i got to punch up
masterpiece i was reluctant to see it i
was reluctant to see it but it was a
damn good movie what was it called is
that what we do
no
what you missed
but it's all obscure words like you know
like you call somebody black tape
oh you don't call somebody black tape
a jig
that's that's for a magician
stand up for yourself no but i like how
chin was like couldn't find a costume
so we just went to his old gangster gear
no this is that casey no no he got out
of his gear for fishing yeah yeah
actually
just talking about the hoodie and
sunglasses that he just
yeah
hey respect chin i know respect me dad
[Applause]
the skateboarder
oh yeah the famous dude viral famous guy
cranberry juice dog face dog face he's a
real trouble
he was the first island boy he was there
his third day and i met yeah that's
blowing up by the way
but their lyrics are starting to come
back to it's not matching up i read i
googled some of their lyrics last night
and i don't think the lyrics are
matching up to their capability what are
you talking about
you mean their reading level yeah
their vocabulary is not very good the
lyrics yeah i mean they can't compete
with kendrick lamar for the father dude
ruben
made a really great picture reuben
stuttered for me
yeah woman was like
what happened to rubens here's the thing
it's on my instagram youtube don't you
believe that that eric knows reuben's
sutter says 110 because i'm an island we
go to the same church
i'm trying to make it oh i'm an island
okay guys stop saying it i feel like
stevie's come around he almost had a
conniption when we were yeah
i don't want to say it
nips bro you know what i'm saying huh
i think it's like uh german koreans
what oh they dropped the n word in there
no they didn't yeah i'm a kiwi
oh yeah dude
wanna keep that guy
but they're black aren't they no they're
no
a it's more of a mentality i think yeah
than a
specie really
theo have you been did you fly here on a
private jet after your netflix drop
no dude i've walked here how's your
response how's the response been brother
after your special i think it's been
fine you don't know you just you know
you hope people like it and then it's
just kind of that's it you know it's
like i don't know i was i was thinking
about that like you hope people like it
it's exciting
and then then it's over what yeah
it's really just content you put out
some you put out some major content on a
major network now you move on and get
ready to do the next thing yeah well my
mama texts me and she knows comedy she
said you tell theo that was amazing
really yep
yeah dude she also
she's also in recovery
so i even appreciate that even more now
she's also seven bottles of wine
just naked watching it like and it
wasn't even me she was watching it
she go i know she's all like theo really
went in on transgender people
still pulled his balls out and pulled
his pants on like mom that's eric andre
i guess something i was thinking was
like
about like evolving as a comedian that's
what i started thinking of do you ha
like
like what is it like what do you need
does it matter if you just like because
i like to tell stories right so like
does it matter if you just tell stories
forever do you have to get your style be
s like you know
i just wonder like do you like look how
chappelle evolved you know i'm saying
obviously he's gotten a little preachy
but still he evolved to
you talking major issues man when before
it was like sesame street and you know
still funny yeah we just evolved got
older
and you did from your last one you
didn't do it intentionally you just did
you got older yeah you just got older
more experience yeah stories
be more about things that are more
personal to you that's relatable yeah
that's all it is that's true i don't i
just think i just think don't overthink
it the holidays are crazy man you can't
even these days it's
with all the uh closeted whatever and
the racism you can barely have a nice
christmas dude yeah you got a growing
business you got to get orders out
you're juggling orders
it's tough bro oh you could barely have
time to touch yourself thankfully you
can make time for yourself you're
talking about ship station because they
make it quick easy and convenient easily
import orders from any sales channel
whatever you're doing man they got over
a hundred thousand sellers use ship
station in their business
you left one of your hairs over here oh
my mail it if you want to mail it if you
want to back in the old days they didn't
have mail so people would have to
hoof it you have to yeah just hope
something got somebody write someone a
tree you know ronnie you owe me money or
ronnie loves belinda or whatever
hopefully ronnie sees it but our
listeners
now our sellers can use shipstation with
their business yep with all the major
carriers you get exclusive discounts on
ups and usps you can compare carriers
small businesses can access the same
rates used for big companies fortune 500
that's right our listeners can use our
code kats to get a 60-day free trial wow
just in time for the holidays ring ding
ding ding that's two months of
stress-free holiday shipping for free
just go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top and enter the code
kats ship station make ship happen
you know half of americans are on high
deductible health insurance hate to see
it and that's a fact you go somewhere
you got a damn tonsillitis next thing
you know it's seventy thousand dollars
and both your children's legs have been
sawed off oh my god dude times are
different for many people in the u.s
concerned about the cost of health
insurance there are no good options
thank god for crowd health it's a
community and you can save hundreds of
dollars monthly put thousands of dollars
back in your pockets flexible it's
simple there's a membership man all
right you use their app you can find any
doctor in any country rank from one to
five stars probably pass on the one star
doug yeah if you want five stars or you
want to be risque and enjoy yourself you
know this isn't even a uh lay this is a
christmas wreath oh that's nice thank
you but i will say this for a limited
time our listeners get their first month
free
and you've been and after you've been a
member crowd health will include a
fitness wearable
it's 30 days to try risk-free plus the
fitness wearable just go to
joincrowdhealth.com
fit enter the code kats at signup that's
join crowdhealth.com
fit promo code cat yep get rid of the
insurance middleman and pass the savings
on to its members crowd health is not
health insurance it's community powered
alternative
terms and conditions may apply i'll tell
you this man i quit going to a lot of
these places that all these big jacked
up insurance prices i've been going to
like wellness centers and things like
that and it really has been saving me
money oh wow
oh wow oh eric yeah that's what some of
that guy that reuben made so that that's
gonna go on a t-shirt takashi nine-nine
got it yeah yeah that's cool that's
coffee 269.
[Laughter]
damn
wow that's a fire you should get your
hair like that now is that the island
boys tattoos
it's brendan or is it takashi 69 no
that's the island that's island boys the
seventeen yeah that's spiritual it's
tough to tell yeah this is a spiritual
dude
yeah have you ever played a roulette
a spiritual dog i listened them for two
hours on no jumper did you oh they're on
no jump i regret it
two hours you'd never get back yeah what
was the i like the no jumper guy uh yeah
i mean adam he's a great great yeah theo
was on it
yeah adam's great i went in there dude
you went on no jumper yeah recently no
respect that's and then what were the
island boys talking about uh just like
how they got discovered gummy bears uh
spending time in jail
uh how old are they uh they're 19 but
they they spent like four years in their
early teens
what were they doing yeah well how do
they get in jail smuggling coconuts
obviously drugs dude uh okay
they also have a video on youtube where
they're both side by side eating out
their girlfriend's buttholes oh well
what's up cooler and cooler
their hair has fentanyl
if we want to know where the fentanyl is
coming from it's definitely coming out
of that new scalp will you guys be open
to have them as guests on
100 well yeah that would be good
let's do a call out to the island boys
if they want to come on
uh yes i don't think they call
themselves that what do they call
themselves no that's their name we could
probably zoom them in right yeah i i've
tried i've been in their ig lives me and
150 other people but like
yeah we rallied the troops our fans that
would be amazing so yeah
instead of hating on me and steve
uh watch out use that energy to get the
island boys on yeah they want all the
smoke yeah that cone dog
that cone boy and how'd you come up with
this cone i bet you're a beautiful baby
man yeah i'm singing the same thing
were you yeah all right can you
understand it
yeah no no no i'm just telling you tell
us about if you had a television i was a
good looking kid yeah so was bobby
quit talking about bobby dude yeah we're
talking he doesn't talk bro because you
know why he doesn't talk about you but
he doesn't at all huh no never
i don't know you guys were brothers huh
huh i didn't know your brother still
theo told me that's true actually nine
episodes deep he goes you know stevie
and bobby or bobby who he was leah
that's his brother holy [ __ ] he didn't
tell you he had a brother no no
he said i'm an only child
that hurts my feelings dude
i want to know what the orange makeup is
yeah hey is that
it looks like dog to burger king
[Laughter]
look you just looked at him like it's
your second wife
like damn i should have stayed with my
proposed to me every [ __ ] day what's
up
the ghostbusters he's actually leslie
jones
he's les jones
[Laughter]
i don't know it's a good tough call like
you you i'll look like i'm headed to
netflix to protest dave chappelle unless
i got kyle with me because then it makes
sense look at him
ghostbusters
small ass dough boy dude that's what's
wrong with america bro they got these
small ass dough boys now yeah don't want
my dough thick man man get that little
breed like they used to uh-huh that's
that little twink dough boy over there
we used to be fat i can't you know dude
so first of all christian had a a
birthday hat on with the point i said
don't don't put that on and put the
let's see it though it's in the card
definitely
well i'm just i i'll tell them i've seen
it when i was growing up dude and then
we all king it or sting it yeah well
king are saying it dude yeah because
look at stevie
dude i got this at target
last year i went all in now is that is
that icing on your face with actual
makeup because i will lick your [ __ ]
face dog
this is real makeup this is i got a
target i went last night and i thought
about it these two latina like teenagers
were laughing at me and i knew if they
were laughing at us yeah they thought it
was a funny costume but you guys seem
not to like it and they're making fun of
me no i don't love it you like me he
just said you know what it looks like
icing on my nose you know i like the
costume there's no serious angry face
coming out of there is so funny
yeah if i was tired it's almost like
he's being born that's why i say you'll
be a beautiful baby what do you mean
you're coming out you're like an orange
vagina you're just coming out of it like
yeah dude like an orange chicken vagina
yeah
you got this
yeah like your mom was a highlighter
yeah tickle that little tickle that
little oompa loompa man you look like a
weirdo
you and your girl are wearing matching
costumes yeah yeah yeah i'd like the
guy's advice on that king you're
stinging it matching costumes with
her thing was and she bought a sewing
kit to add stuff to it and i said what
is this
it's my costume we're going to make it
all lit like yeah yeah stevie what do
you think man
couples matching costumes i want to hear
what stevie has to say i think it's a
cute idea and then it's you know it's a
collective group thing
and uh both parties are involved i think
king it my whole family's star wars
like boston's yoda which you'll [ __ ]
get a kick out of back off by the way
back off back off you told me he said he
goes did uncle theo get my email i told
no means no he keeps looking at me and
all the photos
you want me to back off dude
i was watching the theo's special little
play in the car
i was watching this
diaper
[Laughter]
eric looks like that uh that burger king
king if he looks like the burger king if
he bought a hundred dalmatians bruh yeah
there you go man you're back
all right so what i told him i saw him
earlier bro if you if you don't wear
that hat like that because that's not
that's not a party hat and the other
thing is
draw a happy face so we know you're not
in the kkk no but yeah but a happy face
on it would just mean he's a happy
racist
they're all happy about being racist
you can barely even find a good races
anymore well no not that hard well not
that hard you're here
i'm the ghost of a traffic cone i'm the
ghost of seabees costume right now oh
thank you now are you are you missing
another half of your costume a horse
okay explain this one brendan oh okay
right horses
oh yeah yeah come on a lot of them don't
though you mean if you're talking about
the kkk from the 1200s or whatever
that's right
yeah but i don't like being in anything
where you have to wear a uniform like
the boy scouts anything like that
yeah it's just annoying we're in
uniforms so like i wouldn't want to be
in a clan either i'd be like can i just
come like this can i just have my
regular stuff on it you know you come in
if you come in your regular stuff though
i think the reason i don't know why they
all wore the uh sheets and all well
because they weren't the reason is
because they were like judges cops
people that they don't want anybody to
see that they are you know where you
kind of know who they were yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah the guy writes judge
on the outside of it yeah
they got like personalized license
plates
you know
it's like i hate n-words as everybody's
that's that's bad yeah
beautiful baby though yes but i think
steve's matching outfit if you if the
girl would be like a dead hooker and
then you're like next you put that next
to it you don't drive around yeah that'd
be fun drive around you know what i mean
that's what that would be that'd be fun
all right or sting it here
hang it or sting it tell me what you
were like as a baby and we'll get into
it yeah i was cute i was a cute little
guy how big were you six pounds eight
ounces no no steve how big were you what
was your life were you this big
big oh
stevie what's your brother gonna be for
halloween do we know disgusting
uh you'd have to ask him
he doesn't do that anymore i don't know
this is the first costume i've worn in
30 years me too i don't really do this
out of anyone i didn't i didn't i i was
hoping everybody dressed up i didn't
think you'd dress up i thought maybe i
didn't even no no i want to be a part of
the fun yeah you won't be the great
halloween grounds yeah
there you go and your roots
you were in roots
i'm talking to the slave guy um
what tell me more about it stevie oh i
don't
we'll uh we'll check in at the end of
the episode but right now stevie's
crushing brendan was a big ass baby
probably in the back seat dude 11 pounds
11 pounds eight ounces what stats are
those uh this is a poll for best king of
the sting best costume contest
as of right now yeah yeah we put it up
at the beginning of the episode tv one
we'll check in at the end of the episode
again it's neck and neck i'm not
quitting but i mean that's nixon
i would pick that look at him i mean
yeah
i should have worn the rat king i know
yeah you should have been the rat king
i freaking sit in his seat he deserves
to be over here huh you deserve to be
over there i i agree with this game i
agree with feel let's do this i gotta
hear that's another one here they act
like i came in here was like hey no no
you're getting messages i'm gonna do it
if i said yeah theo you over there
like you act like i did this that's your
throne it's all the same team now that's
your throne it's all the same team do
you feel uncomfortable about it
sometimes
bro hey you i don't know why you pay
attention to any of that hate we all
love it
i get it
wow that's terrible that that's a
terrible story it's like rapunzel's
actually transgender
they're pulling dudes up like nah i got
you
wait in two weeks that book will be out
pronouns are heard his transponder
transparent
time stamp that transparent
you know you know what i don't know why
they don't do that you know how they you
know they they take all the guys stuff
and they do like the female version of
it the next step is to do transgender
versions of all the stories you know
black annie was what took that's what
ruined everything when they did black
annie oh it ruined even black people
were like
what's happening here
[Laughter]
and then and then when they did the uh
the wonder years the all black editions
they didn't do that
seven people watched they did that you
know what you know what i'm mad they
didn't pick up the show i was on for
that show what was it called
it didn't don't even matter but i was i
i did a pilot for abc and they picked up
that show instead of ours yeah you know
you ain't mad about it yeah you know it
happens man should we see what this
guy's saying is
what's going on theo brandon big griff
stevie i got the king of the stinger for
you guys
[ __ ] pumpkins
every time my girl goes to the store she
comes back with a new [ __ ] pumpkin
everything
[ __ ] pumpkins
my girl too man our [ __ ] looks like a
goddamn haunted house she does i love it
she goes all out my kids love it are you
doing a haunted house this year we i did
it uh last week i went to horror nights
universal was it good wait wait you went
you went to horror nights
that was a few years ago and that was in
costa rica i went to a horror night
universal
you know what i realize i i'm too old
for haunted houses the dude rolls his rs
he rolls his b's l's
joint yeah
yeah
yeah but you know it doesn't count for
you because you have kids yeah so like
anything so
it's for them
but this guy i don't know if this guy
has kids this guy this guy he's dating a
kid you know what i mean
she feels weird what do you think about
this because you're orange they talk
about orange things i like it i like it
i think it's you know she's you know
she's getting seasonal with it did you
decorate the apartment
what did you just say well stevie's
house already has like that haunted
house
you should have been a red cones
questions about a baby
next week you bring in some baby
pictures okay we'll see you later
i'll bring you something we'll all bring
in baby pictures and we'll let the fans
decide all right yeah
big
thing baby i love it you like that mic
or stay in it
that's what i think
what would it be nick what would clan
understand clan would be you really hate
something and stan it you're a super fan
yes yeah
plant understand it dude that's a new
series yeah
i love you stevie looks insane dude we
could talk about stuff we got [ __ ]
eric here dog what's going on here oh
she's got a good one for us
she's got two good ones for us
oh
this is what brendan thinks he looks
like right now
my name is ellie i am from slovenia so
we're bringing a bit of that beach
slavic to this show you know we're
bringing a balcony biscuit to spice
things up
[Music]
some of the richest people in the world
on their big fancy boats
[Music]
but i'm home at the moment so it's time
to have some fun
i have a question for you i
love costumes outside of halloween i
literally travel with costumes we got a
freak any occasion to pull out the
costume auntie
yeah yeah
you know you notice how he like he
puffed up this part right here
yeah everything's fine uh what are you
doing my question for you is
do you like costumes in the bedroom
do you like your girl to dress up and
what is your ultimate turn on my
personal favorite
everybody hallelujah
this is my signature look i love this
costume any chance to pull it out i will
do it so let me put out
which one is your favorite
for you
love the show theo you're my favorite
comedian
thank you for the laughs
oh she's a bad boy
that's it costumes in bed
you know like yeah in the bedroom wear
different wigs and [ __ ]
if your girl's bad enough you don't need
to dress all that [ __ ] my favorite
lingerie is titties
my love language is suck and dick you
feel me you guys are just waiting
you take it we got to get that wig off
of him before dude you're like well i
hold you down
you look like sharon taint
somebody should hit you with that axe
you look a horrible dog
but it's great but it is great man
you're a great guy
hey she likes you man
she likes you brother she's in slow
my friend she's in can't even pronounce
it i know she said she's your fan no
she's beautiful and i wouldn't happily
go over to
your town
you don't know where it's at get to see
you it's in the baltic ocean brendan and
you're a big massage guy she's a massage
therapist that's true
i got a massage today for this guy
bike bike bike you know that guy
so he's
oh now are you fully nude during the
massage or just a towel in your undies
how do you get down i take both my socks
off i put one of my socks on the thing
put my honestly my penis and weiner in
the sock nut into the other side
like i'm concerned how do you do it
so i am nude but i have my privates in
one of my own socks
so how do can you display it real quick
is it the no see socks or we're talking
like a long tube
what do you mean you mean the socks that
you wore there do you do so you do this
and do it in a sock like you put this in
the sock yes okay yeah bro that's all i
want to know yeah okay
right yeah okay and you feel protected
i mean i know them there i know them
it's a family they have a little baby
named elroy i think is his name right
his name's bike bike and the son's
name's elroy yeah weird his boy elroy a
lot of people name their kids stuff from
jets
out of vietnamese people name their kids
stuff from cars that makes sense
yeah shin i'm not gonna be stand up for
us man
asian is asian i don't know yeah
asian hate is asian all right
doesn't chin have a brother named
voltron
it was her favorite cartoon and her
sister he-man
our balkan biscuit has another
submission for a game i don't think
stevie and eric have played yet balkan
biscuit the balkan business dude is that
her website
epic the legendary
name
game
daddy yes
we're doing halloween edition
any murder or monster from either a
movie or a tv show both come on there we
go you guys got this we need to zoom her
in
she needs to be zoomed in immediately
i want to know what's going on
well on that outfit you look like you
subscribed to 17 different only fans
accounts thank you very much actually
have you ever seen hawaii i'm a wine guy
hey oh i'm in jamaica i mean jamaica
what was your question
name game name game mode we're movie
villains killers or or monsters i think
that's fair that's a good name game so
how does it how do we play start with
theo
all right i'll start and it's it's just
just you four oh oh so we're all playing
yeah okay like classic monsters like
monsters in any movie okay are we naming
horror movies too does that count just
the villain or the monster from it so if
it's out if it's friday the 13th yeah
jason all right go ahead are we going
clockwise we're going to cheetah ortiz
count or no
this is fun there's fun
good thing you checklisted okay no
worries
i'm gonna go with uh frankenstein
i'm up next dracula
christine
freddy krueger
jason voorhees
count it
just because i want the game to keep
what take that the mummy
dracula
oh i didn't hear you that's brendan's
move yeah
yeah he said stuff quiet and he didn't
know he said it either yeah but i'm ct
you have no excuse i wasn't even okay
but you're still the king leather face
i guess since we kept ended so early
yeah keep going until there's another
face michael myers
when didn't somebody say jason
different people different people all
right all right michael myers is
halloween
most people listen to people buying time
to think but brendan is just him just
saying stuff
uh white drac a vampire
uh different
no no i'm just a vampire you said
dracula you just said the word yeah but
draca and vampire is different
you all don't know your horseshoes i
feel like vampires
all right give them a pass for this
round that's fine a vampire they're not
the same that does the kingdom do you
know a specific vampire though that
would be the name
uh like the lost boys vampire la
interview with the vampire brad pitt the
vampire tom cruise
zelda from pet cemetery the decrepit
sister yep bowser
bowser children battled for decades
that millions of children online on he
knows what he's talking about brendan
and in the early 90s
swamp thing
from ghostbusters he wasn't a bad guy he
was a cute pet slimer he was a villain
don't try to get me
out of this one man back off king okay
that counts right guys sure thank you
um i'm gonna go with uh
the one and only
wario
get off mario's nuts bro that's all you
got there's bad guys in mario wow he's
staying on martin we're just gonna let
that roll huh i'll go with the
marshmallow man from ghostbusters
you brought this [ __ ] down yeah i
brought him
i'm talking about the big one though not
the little twink one oh predator
predator
that's good
i'm gonna go with um
abyss
what the hell is that would that move a
sigourney weaver i know but that's not a
creature that's the oh she's seen the
movie they were scared for two hours
i'm gonna call stevie the winner you
can't call the ocean
i feel like me and stevie are still
going
give him a pass
vampires like saying um
yeah vampire you gotta be specific
bowser
say you're like co-signing oh
huh werewolf jack nicholson werewolf do
we want specific movies
we want specific [ __ ] oh yeah uh
jacqueline werewolf i don't want to be
the judge
you have to name the actual
werewolf name
yeah the news judgmental in here get a
little freaking uh kkk guy to do it yeah
wait wait wait wait you're up yeah name
something no no no you're the judge oh i
said jack nicholson in the movie
werewolf okay that's fine uh nobody's
hurting that's fine yeah uh reagan from
the exorcist linda blair reagan aka
exorcist damn okay steve's going in oh
you going and uh you going like that
yeah
we're doing this i want to let's do this
we'll just go to somebody else's first
instance he's going to be like we should
go to somebody else you can't rename the
things we said that's true obviously
okay go ahead you did it go ahead you
know what i will
something
that's why they love games they make it
go go ahead go ahead taiko go ahead
i don't know i'm flustered go ahead yeah
jaws wow the shark good one that is good
oh the swamp thing dirty i said it yeah
are you sure guys yeah sorry pal
you said swamp thing it's fine i don't
remember him you're just a baby i gave
you guys okay that's fine you're fine
i'd say stevie do you feel bad though
because everybody else got passes and
steve didn't get a pass yeah let's run
it back no no no no no no no no
that's it now you're right
i lost you're in no no no i'm out i'm
rude no we all got a pass that's yours
we got it
okay i shouldn't have to go next i don't
think
uh i can go the nun from the conjuring
movement you just said that no i didn't
get to say it because theo went next so
i'm still in you okay go ahead eric go
ahead what i just went no no it goes
clockwise okay i'm gonna go cruella
deville
so we're going backwards now yeah go
alien mm-hmm
the alien alien
ridley scott alien all right um
let's see
captain crunch
oh no he's out sugar's bad for people
yeah that's not it would make the the
top of your mouth
it would like rip up the top of your
mouth
yeah
sugar count chocolate
right that's fire that's fair well what
are we doing cereals
fentanyl
you know how many asian cities godzilla
has trampled through fairplay
i'm just saying it's true the facts yeah
yeah
i mean how many dumplings godzilla's
eating yeah i'm gonna go with gremlins
wait wait wait what is the name of the
gremlins howie mandel no though before
they turn into a monster
uh he's both or no no because they're
not scary when they're before that
that's what you're talking about gizmo
i'm talking about the gremlins
right that counts
we got to finish this up speed round now
oh kerry yep god damn it that was in my
head it's a [ __ ] good for you steve
oh man stephen king carrick island boy
go ahead go ahead oh i got a good one
paul ryser in aliens
he's out he's out
yeah was the enemy in that movie
but he has a name too yeah piece of [ __ ]
[Applause]
no i thought i could just say hello
uh i got one cujo
cujo what's great that's good all right
um
[Music]
polar express was scary the last couple
like the middle it was a draw guys good
job you know what i don't like
and this is a fact bub fatty sorry
fatty it was an accident or no you said
you meant paddy yeah yeah my bad
patricia
uh what i don't like is some of the uh
dining app delivery app sure they they
let all these big companies advertise
you only see the same companies over and
over again we do not like that man i
don't like you you don't want to i don't
like going to restaurants i like to be
in my underoos am i cozy staying at home
eating drinking snackies all day
that's why i use grubhub man grubhub
works hard to serve restaurants so they
can work hard to serve you get hard
brother and eat that's what i'm saying
staying up to date on the latest
grubhub's got you covered dude give them
that panera deal though oh panerai i
know you like panera you look like a
panerai i'm a bready boy
today's grub hub doing a little extra to
serve panera get a free delivery perk on
your first order from panera of 15 or
more order through the grubhub app or
online grubhub we serve restaurants yep
they serve restaurants man damn
it's that time of year man look if you
put 200 on deandre swift the other day
maybe you're worth
maybe you made some money maybe you did
and listen the pigskin is flying and
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner the nfl we got
you covered new customers can bet just
five dollars on any nfl team
to win their game if they do you win 200
and free bets winner winner chicken
dinner yup if the sports book isn't
available in your state yet draftkings
won't leave you empty-handed everyone
can play for huge cash prizes all season
long
draftkings giving new customers a free
shot at millions of dollar
and that's for everybody whether you are
asian or not whatever you want man
download the draftkings sportsbook app
now use promo code k-a-t-s
just bet how much friends five dollars
on any nfl team to win their game and
win two hundred dollars in free bets if
they win you win with the promo code
kats this week at draftkings sportsbook
the officials want that hammer huh i got
must be 21 or older new jersey
indianapolis or pa only pennsylvania new
customers only
minimum five dollar deposit and one
dollar wager required one per customer
restriction supply see
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gamble gambler yeah and look
only play this if you're safe if you
have a gallon problem yeah don't maybe
get some help for yourself call that
number if you don't you like to bet on
some games this is your space i'm a bad
[ __ ]
let's see what papa bear is going to say
cesaro our buddy he uh did some music
for us and has been on sync my ink
soft fellas i know i look like i took a
genius pill since the last time you saw
me but it's actually just glasses
and no i'm not at a car dealership as
you can tell by this
kickboxing class punching bag that's in
this room but this is my new home i live
in like this mansion in south jersey i
started the company
during the pandemic
pretty successful doing pretty pretty
big things so
live a good life and uh yeah i grew my
mustache because you guys made fun of me
so cool thanks and i got my tattoos
finished because you guys made fun of me
so
cool and then i made a song for your
album and i hope you heard it because
it's [ __ ] awesome if not you should
play it right now on your show so
everyone can hear it because it's a
masterpiece
so my king interesting it is
i gotta be quiet because my wife doesn't
know this my kindest thing is
living in a house
that someone was murdered in
because a doctor murdered his wife in my
house
when we first got this house
the way the person told me the story it
sounded like it happened somewhere else
but now i found out that it happened
here in the master bedroom and then i
sleep oh no it happened here no no
in the house i live in haven't you seen
the conjuring so i can't understand it
living in a house that someone was
[ __ ] murdered in that they're making
a documentary about hearthstone that's a
hard time well i'm all about i'm all
about the discount i need answers fellas
yeah dude that's a haunted house dude
like the king bro this is awesome
this is price king though
yeah
so you would live in a haunted house
and he knew too he just didn't tell his
wife dude mine in negotiations the guy
was like
it's a hundred thousand off you know
what i mean
how about my coach in college bought the
jonbenet ramsay house where she was
murdered in the basement
like you know there's a lot of people
who are into that kind of stuff yeah you
could have been in those shows pageants
well what are you talking about
i would think if you got it here's my
thing i kill on stage i kill at home bro
you know what i'm saying dog so if if
the wife got to go the wife got to go
not everybody could you know we can't
all be we can't all be winners there it
is boom i'm sorry i'm gonna this is a
song yeah let's do it
on the king of the stained albums
and put them on their back scrapping the
cage in the book stacks got up on stage
spitting the facts making them laughing
that [ __ ] was a wrap married the game
and he ain't gonna tap putting the reps
in the show on the stats roll up our
mountains
[Music]
over the map words of wisdom that he
drops in your lap love you though love
you for that kitty cat looking like a
whole snack chappelle looking like a
decent small cracker
[Music]
charles
[Music]
that's a throwback to a different time
in a different place with a different
mind you try to stick my ink but you
know that's tight i will flaunt
[Music]
is yeah i like this guy
wow man i like this guy yeah this guy's
awesome
i like this guy i'm still curious what
is theo's costume dog yeah theo what's
going on there you're the ghost of mtv
spring break
yeah oh there you go you're tom selleck
dude you're tom from magnum pi yes [ __ ]
yeah the wi-fi i found it let's go with
my hands so fast yeah dude stay
connected like that why five oh hell
yeah
yeah
wow
what's going on here huh hello oh cone
you ain't going nowhere yeah oh yeah
yeah
oh okay oh damn oh this guy's for real
this one is brendan's old like old girl
this is one of your girls from costa
rica brandon
all right before you guys accuse me of
cultural appropriation i got a king
understand for y'all
cultural appropriation type of costumes
obviously i'm rocking the luchador mask
yes i am white but you know it gives me
a chance to hit some devious licks on
halloween night and blame it on my
little mexican neighbor
well
let me know and let the world know what
you guys think gang gang buzz
everything is good to go as long as
you're gonna go blackface yeah you can
do anything well i could be here wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait hold
on
hold on a second there was one part
there
that part where he said he blamed it on
his mexican
the bad part
but what if it makes your neighbor as
being you know
a little too messy yeah
yeah so in what way is he being too
mexican that's that's a lot of ways that
it could happen
hot cheetos at his doorstep all the time
yeah doing quinceaneras all night long
yeah just for no reason yeah yeah just
unlimited quinceaneras dog jimmy john
are you the chamberlain at that uh
he got no daughters but he's throwing
quinceaneras man that's it that's
illegal i'm saying you're thirsty give
him cortada
yeah well i don't listen i i i have a
serious thought about this
about my serious thought about this is
at what point do we try to move on in
the world i agree as opposed to like
always living in the past like what do
we want kids to know about like if a kid
is legitimately like hey i want to do
this thing and it's so innocent and it
means nothing to them other than fun you
just can't go blackface you know i don't
think you should be able to though it's
all
we're one generation asked jimmy kimmel
dude he did it he did him alone oh yeah
he did the car malone yeah and you think
he was friends with carmel you think he
did it to be mean no yeah i think a lot
of it is intentional the people that
make it bad is the media man [ __ ]
nailed it because kids
that's my ghostbuster gun
well that's fun grow up but what i'm
saying is this there you go right there
there he is hilarious
that's jimmy kimmel yeah no he was
trying to come after people and cancel
him wow yeah
that was what's insane yeah now here's
the thing man if she can't even ball he
can even ball though no then that's
[ __ ] that's wrong
with the one we should be cancelling uh
people don't know it but he impregnated
a 13 year old when he was in college
that's why i got the nickname the
mailman figure it out yo yeah right
tropic thunder a robert downey he did it
he did and he was any character and it
was funny you do that these days but
that was he also won an oscar if you
paint yourself black and you run out and
you start yelling i'm an n word yeah
people different that's not right
that's [ __ ] that kind of stuff is in
it's not it's not right it's not funny i
don't just say it's not these are
serious matters
but here's you know what is interesting
i noticed you can't people are getting
so diverse now with mixed race and stuff
you can't even beat like the old racist
it doesn't even make sense anymore
because everyone's saying everyone's a
melting pot people so mix you can't you
have no half the crowd is mixed don't
say anything you're gonna offend me if i
wanna
everyone's mixed because you are you
have blackface built in to you yeah
which is pretty cool you get a you know
i have i'm light faced came with it
okay but i don't know so it's all
context and oh it's all context i know
but the context is lost nuance is lost
because people get upset about something
lost on the media though i think no no i
think that there are there's the only
lost in hollywood i think the only gen
the older generation is still holding on
to these things too and i understand
young kids the other ones woke online no
no but it is like the older generation
is also remembers what this really meant
that you know what does what really mean
what is the death what does that really
mean being woke woke is when you don't
have the words to articulate your
position
and that's being wrong
then you say woke
yeah because by the way you could say
woke on either side like say pig
abortion you could be like you know why
i'm pro-life because i'm woke you know
why i'm pro-choice because i'm wallow
so that's why people don't it means
nothing yeah what do you think of that
cone i thought it means you know about
the aliens just like your woke you know
about other extraterrestrials maybe
that's what people they would say that
that's what they're the original bigfoot
people say that too yeah
y'all
yeah okay i was just i was curious yeah
a lot of people like uh the woke nest
monster whatever that thing whatever
yeah that'd be great the whole nest
monster comes out of the ocean and
starts like you know you guys need to
it'll be a funny skit yeah
our pumpkin guy had a second good uh
king at her stage oh i love him
can we go can we play his first one
again more
time funny pumpkin pumpkin i want to see
his girl this girl's going to be furious
when she sees this she's my brother [ __ ]
you i'm trying oh she's going to watch
her she's going to watch it dress like
he has pumpkin she's making his house at
home he should not take that from her
that is nice actually listen
look at that
over here
look at this
[ __ ] over here
it's so sensitive
[ __ ] over here
nothing sadder you get home and ain't no
decorations ain't no damn little orange
cupcakes yeah you're right no no
presents under the tree yeah imagine you
you go home later you take this off and
masturbate yeah and that's your
halloween bro you know what i'm saying
oh he's making lives
he's making
pancakes on the hot plate come on
dude nick's future having bingo down to
the downstairs tonight so it will be
fine
beautiful baby awards
that's me yeah
you're doing something to me this
morning it's called a pressure really
you're really impressed in this that's
impressive
that's okay what's going on theo brandon
big griff stevie i got a king of
stinging for you guys
[ __ ] pumpkins yeah baby every time my
girl goes to the store she comes back
with the new [ __ ] pumpkin
everything somebody should put music
into this you know what i mean our
placemats pumpkins our coasters pumpkins
our doormats
we said hey they're pumping
it [ __ ] pumpkins
bro can you find that guy's tick tock
for me i got to put that on my tick tock
that's good
his girl don't even know
she's about to like memphis because
because he seems like very good
he got a personality like he just goes
with the flow yeah you know what i mean
so his girl does all this stuff and he
she's like what do you think baby he's
like it's cool
this will be the most they've
communicated yeah oh yeah do you think
she'll really watch this oh yeah yeah
someone's gonna say what you did honey
his friends
yeah sorry i'm trying to make this
apartment a home
you know yeah so we'll talk to the
falcon bunny or biscuit and him yeah we
gotta get biscuit on all right let's see
this second one gang gang what's going
on
you know the last few years
they've been tough man it's been getting
tougher you just peed on his foot
coercing
chocolates out of my more fortunate
neighbors
but uh
you know i usually come away with a few
things you know i noticed that it helps
a little bit
if you pretend you have some sort of
mental impairment disability you have
some autism on the spectrum or maybe
some of the uh syndrome yeah
normally
you can color us a few more of those
chocolate hitters
hey pause the real good day i'm getting
i'm getting i don't have a job vibes
after this
yeah this might be a small apartment bro
and also when you have nothing to do all
day you do [ __ ] daddy yeah yeah
that's that'd be funny this girl's
probably like what'd you do all day like
i did interviews
yeah i was on monster.com
so what is the king understanding adult
trick-or-treating essentially going on
without kids bro if you're a grown man
you come asking you're no [ __ ] kids
i don't know but also though you do you
know you do this brandon you all send
y'all children up there and then look in
a bag and get something dude if i know a
house giving out the full candy bar i
tell my son we're going back around dog
we're taking a lap around the block and
going back to that house you give them a
second costume
but y'all rich your neighbors giving all
kind of stock tips probably they give
you cryptocurrencies yeah gasoline cans
of gas
over there
the gas is expensive so i guess i will
yeah they gave i remember getting some
[ __ ] wild [ __ ] when i was a girl do
you remember them dumb [ __ ] those
older ladies give you like pennies or
apples
you got some nerve theo's on there but
he was getting full cans of beer
yeah the apples
[Laughter]
yeah beautiful guy too
what up fellas it's your boy josh coming
out of penn state
i just had a question for y'all
i'm wondering
what the weirdest [ __ ] y'all ever seen
handed out of trick-or-treating is just
has that spitters are uh we once had a
lady in my grandma's neighborhood
handing out fruit kebabs
nobody want that [ __ ] man come on don't
trust it
kebabs gang gang buzz buzz gang baby p.s
brandon you look like a roblox version
of channing tatum you ugly [ __ ]
what that's all right
yeah but the kiss didn't help at the end
oh
i think he's struggling with his
pronouns yeah and his face
right that close-up look at the face if
he had this wig on we'd all want to
smash
he's one frat party away from being
arrested yeah yeah yeah yeah it looks
like a white paula costa ooh a little
bit i would say a caramel apple
because it's you know i mean it's a
caramel
no i mean he said trick-or-treating
something weird that's a big thing to
give out to kids it's a great gift the
best i know but that being no but the
thing about the caramel apple is if it's
not wrapped up then you gotta like
people gotta you gotta hand it to them
like this then they gotta eat it on the
spot that's homemade dog and i'm mad
about that
[ __ ] i'm trying to like how
many all those caramel apples you have
to grinch a halloween over here i love
that man
you can't put it in the bag so now you
have to have it now i have to eat it
yeah yeah right on the spot yeah
somebody made that damn apple yeah
yeah yeah people but
mulening them over and they spanked her
from mexico when you eating them [ __ ]
dog yeah you appreciation dog yeah you
are they're delicious yeah
mules baby
so king people over here mule in them no
he's asking what is the weirdest thing
you've ever seen but not a caramel apple
i don't think that was a weird okay i
think the lady giving out change or like
when they give out the just the healthy
treats and [ __ ] yeah they're the healthy
things
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah give me an example give
me an example everybody give you a
little goldfish or some carrots
it's like having counseling it's like
having counseling at a whole house you
know what i mean yeah yeah
goldfish huh
holy moly i'll tell you one strange
thing ladies do she the individually
wrapped fig
newtons whoa that's weird weird dude
that's weird i enjoyed it remember this
individual
it's different no that's a little cookie
you're not giving people out packs
you're not giving out a 16 pack of fig
newtons to like every you know that's a
lot of money so you have to open the fig
newtons and just and you got to wrap
them up and give people
pick one
like styrofoam or something like no no
inside like maybe some plastic
you ever see them lazy [ __ ] they put
out the candy and says don't ring the
doorbell just take one oh no that ticked
off every kid just [ __ ] empty
sometimes they have cancer though and
they can't keep coming to the door
because they don't have enough energy i
didn't think about that
but yeah [ __ ] did not feel bad
because i did that
goldfish you and you no i didn't say i
said you guys i was just wondering what
kind of treats you guys had growing up
chin can you help me out well that's
what you said you said that we are kind
of people kind of go for all kinds of
people is there a specific type of
korean treat here we go
did they give out like crispy seaweed or
some [ __ ] rice cakes where there you go
that's interesting breast cakes weird
sugar
can we see halloween rice cakes that's
not weird though rice cakes ain't weird
that's [ __ ] weird that's weird right
rice cakes why do you all get pissed at
hey i'll get pissed every treat y'all
get and both y'all honestly a little
thick so y'all obviously enjoying some
treats you third thickest in the room
[ __ ] don't act like
yeah that's weird rice cakes is weird
right you didn't get corn dogs in your
neighborhood
and these are like the healthy rice
cakes or like no they're actually korean
rice cakes so they're made with like
rice they're covered in sugar yeah they
have sugar in it it's really sweet
that's what i'm saying is now
korean rice cake but i mean yeah they're
like you have to elaborate because they
might think they're all the same oh hey
you know what korean chin you know what
it is you know what you think a rice
cake is that's a rice krispie treat doc
no no that's duck that's that's dog
that's a different type of rice oh boy
no duck google is racist
stalking you bro
yeah it's delicious delicious
no they had they put it in soup stews
but what is it like uh it's a rice cake
it's a rice cake yeah it's just a sauce
it's nice yeah it's not dry they have
like open barbecue pits outside the
house
during halloween because everybody had
to come cook their own like some of
those yeah you got to just stick up yeah
that's stuck yeah that's tough you grab
look at them little things trying to
yeah
there's different colors yeah
sometimes what they have been uh
beans
yeah
looks like sushi though yeah no no
that's rice that's rice cake but it just
looks like sushi yeah it does the way
they have yeah
you know what i'll bring some next time
i'll i'll go to the store so you guys
could really taste it you know
it's chin all right i'll bring some
thoughts
you know what i'll bring you guys though
you know what i am surprised that you
guys don't have haven't had that more
often like you know you guys know you
know when you go to like uh
like food people don't you know give you
guys like be like you know like you know
you go to morning radio and there's like
the local teriyaki guys like oh i
brought some food for everybody yeah
we need to get some more of that going
on here like a cultural crisis
outside when we leave here i got a food
truck with chuck liddell if you guys are
hungry really yeah we got a food really
yeah
cool
but i'll eat again so we got a cats in
the wild on eric griffin sighting oh
let's see let me guess the nose
i know but they said they said they want
to be uh you want to be you for
halloween man
that's cool that's why i should have
sell though it's flattering
a little honey damn that does look like
you man minus the hitler mustache that
doesn't look
that's beautiful dude that's beautiful
who sent that in uh that's cute man this
is one of the common jokes though that
you know they do a lot yeah everybody
says that oh you look like you have your
nose and mustache
little fella after you've heard that 100
and i wish my name was spelled correctly
it's the rik but it's fine it's fine
he's a victim and everything
never ends huh there's that that's my
costume
it's a
king and a sting couple what is going on
game of thronesy king of the story oh
yes
oh nice i like that i met that guy she's
a little bumble bee oh yeah
that's cute buzz buzz young lady and if
there's any more king interesting it uh
king in the sting costume send him in
we'll look at him next week from the
weekend dude they could also be iowa
fans iowa fans cracks hawks guys hawkeye
hawkeyes oh guys is that it that's it oh
man
we did it guys yeah we did happy hour
i like the trivia game you know what i
missed getting that halloween was good
with the people make the popcorn balls
ooh i love it what's that what's that
the colored popcorn balls caramel
popcorn caramel popcorn ball someone had
a little food coloring yeah yeah yeah
yeah my favorite's the butterfingers the
little small butterfly i like all the
chocolate on there oh yeah do you
remember your last [ __ ] like what like
you're
when you were a kid what's the last
costume you wore as a kid i don't
remember eminem
really oh that's the candy or wrapper
willy wonka style candy
those are fantastic that looks good
that's good shout out theo those are my
favorite the red one yeah with cinnamon
sometimes the last costume was the kid
was a m m candy yeah i was a blue eminem
but what did you got oh oh well we did
all we had was raggedy ann that was it
he was all ragging in my mom had nine
raggedy in costumes everybody was
raggedy nothing wrong with that it was a
little weird the whole family raggedy
[Laughter]
that sounds weird your whole family was
raggedy
every year raggedy ass family every year
sometime we had uh
then in high school would i do oh
where's waldo i did that literally eight
years before anybody else did that the
know the costume this year is going to
be every every [ __ ] going to be uh from
a squid game
you're right some people get canceled
because they're going to do something
with their eyes with their eyes yeah and
i think the island boy is going to be a
big one too oh that's true perfectly
timed yeah you're the first one to do it
if they would have made costumes and so
just the hair just all you need is the
hair piece and everything else tattoos
or just buy the the stick on tattoo
because like a few years ago like when
uh what did you call it um um what's the
margot whatever ravi yeah oh when she
was the suicide yeah
yeah harley quinn like that was a big
costume for the last four years ultimate
[ __ ] yeah yeah just harley quinn harley
quinn you know so now we you know yeah
they love harley yeah yeah yeah i mean
remember underoos underoos are fun to
wear yeah
yeah and love it steve probably has
i had some i did have something to not
be shocked
yeah yeah
that's that queen's biscuit doug what's
that from damn i just googled harley
quinn costume god dawg
that's harley harley buns right there
yeah yeah i don't even know what costume
people could be i gotta be a costume
are you going somewhere just halloween
you're just gonna be a cop what are you
gonna do theo i don't have no idea
come trick or treating me and the kids
yeah you should do it over there where
y'all going in y'all's neighborhood yeah
it's great you ain't got no sidewalks in
that [ __ ] now we do you all right up
the street dog really yeah yeah why
don't you do that it's lit over there
well you got that bougie neighborhood
it's rich over
coming by him you live by whitney huh oh
that's a nice neighborhood thanks dude
yeah
kind of hurts the kids though because
the houses are so so far apart yeah a
lot of other people dude they have a big
house i know
he's part of my hobbies no i'm just
guessing because whitney's
hard to be a fit kid with all them hills
right we've been giving out podcast
clips over there probably
just drop it in your bag
and hair dye
and all the little girls can come wash
themselves in the on the
on the fountain they got money already
she's probably giving out money yeah
she's rolling in she might be giving out
four dollars five dollars man money and
horse feed that would be the weirdest
thing to give out what you open the door
and somebody just give you five dollars
i'd be stoked to get some little kid off
your property though oh yeah [ __ ] it for
two dollars yeah but then that would
that would spread fat you'd have a lot
of house dog we had some old lady giving
out two dollar coins
really yes that's cool that's cool
yeah dude remember when uh people would
say instead of the end where they'd like
what's up my ninjas people would say
that for a while
that literally like right when that came
out i was at my sep family's house and
they opened the door halloween the first
family all black ninjas oh
black dad three black sons or daughters
did you say what's up
i didn't say nothing yeah you said
what's up everybody yeah
you'll be like hey
this is a trap yeah
yeah see what y'all trying to do
is just a camera crew ready you got that
body cam on that young one yeah we got
my friend morgan
but the old days bro we used to invite
my buddy pug across the street we get on
a sit on the uh rooftop with all these
pellet guns and invite pug over and just
cap him right when he got into the
street oh damn oh you were probably you
were that kid what was that
was he dressed up when you chewed him he
was probably dressed up because that's
fun yeah he was dressed up like a little
like a tr sometimes like a little uh
trojan horse or like a little uh
centurion yeah dude those things hurt
the the bb gun [ __ ] yeah yeah are you
gonna let your kids not when you're a
kid they hurt more as an adult like a
red riding hood skin is thinner yeah and
you're also thinking about it too as an
adult you're like i can't believe you're
you know you're yeah my eye or something
you know
when you're a kid you don't you don't
even care the kid you go shoo me yeah
yeah yeah what i mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
those are the games well fellas happy
halloween yeah this week's getting itchy
i can't believe halloween's already here
man
another year
this no this is the start of the
nonsense season so you talk about we got
halloween we're going to go into
thanksgiving then all the christmas
shopping and all that kind of stuff you
know so this is erickson hate it you
know what my girl said the other day
yeah they're ready to hate yeah i'm just
yeah you the grinch dog of holidays hey
you know when you don't when you but
does your girl expect fancy gifts no
listen listen i am better about it now
because now i have somebody to share
stuff with they used to be real sad yeah
when i was like just a single dude you
know christmas come around and it's just
like i gotta go to my mom's place and
that's it you know what it makes you
feel like a loser you need you need to
have family and you have the people to
share it with like last year was the
first year i i remember for thanksgiving
i cooked a turkey myself and we invited
a couple of our friends over and i was
like oh man so thanksgiving meant more
to me
last year for the first time because i
made it a family thing so that's what i
mean it's like so all you out there
if if you're like especially because of
like the pandemic type stuff you know
get some friends you know eric's house
well we're not gonna do that give them
your address yeah they could they can
find it i'm gonna make your new house i
say blaze up a giant if you got your
[ __ ] little thick cousin over there
and yeah they didn't have a little
something yep
yeah yeah thanksgiving's probably great
at your place the best theo comes over
you come over to this place i've seen
them fine i was invited
you have been over there i'm not allowed
is that a pity invite no never he's
always by himself so i haven't come over
with the fam
does he
i brought it one time i think a couple
times oh no tiger's birthday brother
date yeah
megan came one time yeah i think he
forced her to call her aunt maggie i was
like all right dude gotta say that all
right man take it easy dude i'll tell
you this i'll tell you who's gonna
really get haunted this weekend is peter
yan dude he's about to get freaking
haunted but yeah
dude give it up
sandman aurora's finest cory santa hagan
man this is just some fighting stuff oh
there's a gonna be a good fight i think
it goes the distance no i think corey
knocks him out
i kind of was
looking at the over two i got two grand
on it error is uh
power is set up
is them them russian boys they're real
durable oh yeah they're tough my boy
corey you knock them out but the cory
they're talking about he's he's been on
food truck he's been on this past
weekend oh friend friend of the show he
went out when i was fighting he came to
jimmy he was 16 never trained before
he's a basketball player now he's
fighting for a world championship jeez
where's he from aurora oh
wait what wait division but he's
fighting a russian 35 oh 135
yeah yeah
russians though that's the new poor yeah
you don't see a lot of black people
fighting anymore because you know it's
not as bad as it was yeah
you see a lot of it i think the russians
took over i don't know the brushes took
over do you if you have to be in a bread
line
you know yeah yeah you coming hard in
the ring you know remember that weather
remembering black was just hitting
asians out of control remember that chin
yeah i mean i saw the news jen thinks
it's a conspiracy theory i just think
they over blew it and then people just
jumped on the bandwagon wait the oh you
think the media over blue yes yep get
them eric what the asian hate stuff i
was hoping yep i was hoping he'd say
keep the same energy around a half black
guy
well they could have made up if this
y'all could have got back at him if
you'd have thrown a couple brothers in
that squid games oh yeah by the way
you're halfway there steal your pants
chop them out oh yeah yeah ooh half
squid half of wine game outfit yeah my
grandfather died in these pants actually
oh
those are haunted oh that's heirloom
yeah it's heirloom was your grandfather
was your grandfather break dancing like
what did he have those on for no he had
these
he was just old and they cut his toes
off because he was smoking he smoked too
much he smoked all you could he had
diabetes i don't know if he had that but
they cut his toes off but um
and then he died but these were the
pants he died that must have been
your muscles
yeah because i was died comfy though
yeah oh it's a very little squid game
yeah yeah it is
you guys finished watching it i'm uh
episode two what i'm talking about
man
it's not my thing really what it's good
great television no i think okay i like
it cause they it's finally it's a
they've beaten up the women everybody's
getting a dose in that [ __ ] yeah they
are crazy yeah the challenges are crazy
because they're not more realistic
they're worrying about that stuff over
here they worry about where they are
they're worried about who's watching to
be like yo you can't treat me no they
don't watch it they're just like do you
see what mark norman tweeted because man
checked out squid games not diverse
enough for me man
[Laughter]
you know what though you let you joke
but that will be the thing that's gonna
become a thing
oh yeah it's what diversity yeah they're
gonna be like they'll find something
i guess which i'm all for
they're gonna have to ask like they're
gonna have to change it where the people
like before they shoot women they got to
be like do i have permission
are they below your head the americans
just going to recreate and [ __ ] cast
matt damon as the main guy you feel me
no bernie nobody feels that yeah he was
in the great wall he got all this sort
of [ __ ] for it the great wall of china
yep he's in the movie great wall they
were so pissed at him theo got a little
matt damon in him though right a little
bit a little bit in the face
yeah
you like you know trailer park day i got
a little matt demon yeah yeah yeah yeah
like if matt damon didn't make it
yeah yeah did the acting didn't work out
yep or if he did lawn care
that's what i should start matt damon's
lawn care oh that'd be fun yeah nasty
with them figs
like if somebody comes up to you and
they're like and they like has that ever
happened to you like they think you're
someone else would you just be like go
dude
there you go
that's been sent in a lot by uh dude
it's very similar to you yeah yeah
dude i was in the gym some kid goes dude
he comes up to me goes hey man are you
tom hardy right i said you ever seen tom
hardy bro you did you just go yes you
should just say yes but that's a
compliment though that's a card he's a
dime piece oh yeah we're sure handsome
dude short yeah i see i've seen tom
hardy [ __ ] that's the problem
you have with it yeah doug
hansen y'all two got the y'all got too
many problems we don't have any problems
yeah you guys are perfectly normal over
there all right love you guys
thank you uh hey i'm doing shows in l.a
before i run my special in dallas
november 4th and 5th i'm at the hall
with the squad and then dallas addison
improv november 11th through the 13th
get your tickets happy halloween i'm
going to be at the uh spotlight casino
december
4th in uh coachella california oh damn
doggy and um you look like the mascot
for coachella right now oh thanks man he
looks sick yeah
aloha to all my hawaiian friends who
celebrate christmas out on the island
and um
what else do we got that's about it
coming up i think uh burlington albany
i'll be in some places next week but i
think those are maybe sold out buffalo
might have some tickets but otherwise
coachella that's it that's what we got
i'm at the house of comedy island in
washington dc
no in uh vancouver that's my next one
coming oh i'm gonna come out the tempe
improv guys
[Laughter]
on monday you're coming to the improv
remember this monday this monday coming
up it's coming up yeah november 1st
i got to write something yeah november
1st steve will be eric griffin and
friends at the lab in hollywood
yeah remember that'll write something
gonna be fine i just you know what's the
worst that could happen i'll just go up
well i told people to bring tomatoes
okay thanks for tuning in where did that
happen
right after we finished let's get a
group pick well
yeah all right let's do it this was our
vietnam bro
october 31st it was us against the world
we was going to get them baby snicker
and we'd all be on the back of mom's car
with the tailgate down and she's rolling
bro
and we're on the back and mom would roll
up by the yard and we would run and jump
off that tailgate into the yard as that
car was going just
like out right out the back of a c-130
man shout out to all of our service men
and women just
tumble roll into the yard lose half your
[ __ ] candy in the wrong whatever
onward
onward
and then your sister would come off with
the last minute she only two years old
and then it was just every step you
could get through the dark grass to get
up to that front door
and the mom is right there and she got
the big bowl and she's dressed up like a
um little cat
and man you hope that snicker was in
there god i loved halloween
[Music]